went to a gas as soon as we practically  could but I think the truth is that what  would have been a big dereliction of  duty would have been for the health  secretary or the government not to try  and do something about this weekend  effect which sees you have these higher  mortality rates at weekends only last  week we had a very tragic piece of  research which shows the impact on baby  deaths and we have to do something about  that and I think the tragedy is that it  took so long for the BMA to want to  actually sit around the table and  discuss it but when they did has doctors  I think they realized that what we're  trying to do is the right thing for  patients and the right thing for doctors  and so I hope now we can make progress  will obviously try and get everyone  who's had their operation canceled  rescheduled as quickly as possible  doctors work extremely hard in hospitals  around this time of year I know they'll  do everything they can to try and make  up for the delay